the very first installment when we  created the story we knew that we are  making a movie of this person a man  which happened to be Bruce Lee's teacher  and we had a truly a historical  responsibility as a filmmaker how we're  gonna go about how we're gonna make a  documentary shooting exactly how his  life involved with Bruce Lee I always  been a Bruce Lee fan and for me it is  very honorable that they were giving me  this role eight years ago and then eight  years later you know plain the third  installment not to mention having mike  tyson's know the additional extra boost  that Mikey gave to the film you know  it's just having Bruce Lee and Mike  Tyson can say more than one more do you  want  but me it was like a life-and-death  situation  leaving says the owner rap days and why  will we ever see a rematch I don't know  um you have to talk to the people who's  writing the checks because a big check